Un marché dans le nord de la France.
Au milieu des clients,
des familles Roms.
Certains mendient.
D'autres se servent sur les étals.
Bien souvent,
ils déclenchent la colère des commerçants.
Les Roms volent,
ce n'est pas pareil.
Ils volent les portefeuilles.
Ils n'achètent pas, ils volent.
Quand un Rom colle une personne,
elle va pleurer cinq minutes après.
Ils ne nous supportent pas.
On n'est pas tous des voleurs.
Voleurs ou pas, les Roms
sont victimes de leur mauvaise réputation.
Même quand ils prennent
dans les poubelles,
ils suscitent
des réactions agressives.
Oh ! Remets-le.
Viens ici !
Remets ça dans la poubelle.
Ils ne comprennent pas qu'on leur donne
après quelque chose de mangeable,
ils mangent les déchets et donnent
aux enfants qui seront malades.
Ce n'est pas du tout comestible.
Bonjour madame.
Certains commerçants
sont plus compréhensifs.
Un restaurateur accepte
de laisser à cette femme
une assiette
que ses clients n'ont pas terminée.
Il a un bon cœur.
Grâce à ce commerçant,
cette femme va prendre son repas.
La France nous plaît.
À la fin du marché,
les Roms récupèrent les invendus.
Ils repartent ainsi
avec des provisions pour la semaine.
Lille, dans le nord de la France,
son beffroi, sa vieille ville,
ses rues piétonnes et ses Roms.
Après Paris, Lille est la ville
qui concentre le plus de Roms en France.
Ils sont plus de 3000
à vivre dans l'agglomération.
Ils ne sont pas bien vus
par la population locale.
Mendicité, incivilités,
récupération dans les poubelles,
les Roms provoquent
la colère des Ch'tis, pourtant réputés
pour leur sens de l'hospitalité.
Dans les maisons
autour des camps, c'est le ras-le-bol.
J'ai été cambriolé deux fois.
Excusez-moi,
je ne peux plus les voir.
Ça fait huit mois
qu'on vit un enfer.
Ce n'est pas un enfer une fois
de temps en temps, c'est tous les jours.
Comment les Roms
vivent-ils en France ?
Installés dans des bidonvilles
insalubres en périphérie des villes,
ils seraient environ 20 000
sur le territoire français.
Leur vie est faite
de débrouille au quotidien.
Pour sortir de la misère,
certains n'hésitent pas
à entrer dans l'illégalité.
Vols, cambriolages,
réseaux d'exploitation d'enfants.
Comment les Roms
viennent-ils en France ?
Gardent-ils des attaches
avec leur pays d'origine ?
Que font-ils
de l'argent gagné ici ?
Ici,
on vit pire que les animaux.
Enquête sur
une communauté qui dérange.
Lezennes,
un village paisible de 3000 habitants,
est situé
à quelques kilomètres de Lille.
À l'entrée du village, un camp de Roms
provoque le mécontentement des habitants.
Aujourd'hui, certains
d'entre eux crient leur colère
sur la place principale.
Ils demandent l'expulsion
des Roms installés sur leur commune
depuis près d'un an.
Hervé Morel est l'organisateur
de cette manifestation.
Nous voulons plus de sécurité,
plus de sérénité dans notre village,
plus de propreté,
plus d'écoute de la ville
qui semble ne pas s'intéresser
aux Lezennois qui sont dans la détresse.
Les Roms,
on ne les veut pas !
Cette mère de famille
a rédigé une pétition.
Elle demande
l'expulsion des Roms au plus vite.
On espère
enfin qu'ils vont réagir.
Parce que je pense qu'à
un moment donné, ça va mal se passer.
Parce qu'on voudrait
revivre, pouvoir dormir.
Sophie et Audrey
sont mères au foyer.
Elles vivent
dans cette petite zone pavillonnaire.
Derrière leur maison, un camp Rom
qui compte une centaine de personnes.
Sophie, où est le camp ?
Il est juste en face.
On ne voit que les abords,
parce qu'ils sont intelligents.
Ils ont construit en profondeur
pour cacher leurs trafics.
En journée, les voitures passent,
il y a des bruits ambiants, tout ça.
La nuit quand c'est calme,
on n'entend que leurs nuisances.
Là, on entend
quelques martèlements.
On voit la personne,
en train de marteler derrière.
On a de la chance,
elle est seule.
Des fois,
ils sont une dizaine à marteler.
Justement aujourd'hui,
les coups de marteau continuent.
Les Roms fabriquent un poêle
avec un meuble de bureau.
Les vapeurs de ce genre de gazinière
indisposent souvent le voisinage.
C'est un peu toxique,
n'est-ce pas ?
Non, ce n'est pas toxique.
- Ce n'est pas toxique ?
Bobby a 22 ans.
Père de deux enfants,
il vit dans cette cabane
avec sa famille
et ses beaux-parents.
Comme tous les Roms
de ce campement, il vient de Bahia Mare,
au nord de la Roumanie.
Cela fait maintenant sept ans
qu'il habite en France,
depuis l'entrée de la Roumanie
dans l'Union européenne.
On m'a dit
que c'était mieux de vivre en France,
car tu peux chercher de la ferraille.
C'est vrai qu'ici, en deux semaines,
je ramasse la ferraille, je la vends,
et je me fais
un peu d'argent pour vivre.
En Roumanie,
il n'y a pas de ferraille.
Quand tu fais les poubelles,
la police te frappe.
La police te frappe ?
Oui, s'ils te trouvent
dans les poubelles, ils te battent.
Le dernier
enfant de Bobby est né en France,
comme le prouve
cet acte de naissance.
Pour ses deux enfants, il touche
100 euros d'allocation par mois.
Il n'est pas le seul.
Maria, elle,
est mère de cinq enfants.
Elle touche
250 euros chaque mois.
Un complément de revenu
intéressant pour la famille.
Son mari, Florine, dit gagner sa vie en
revendant des pièces détachées de voitures
aux garagistes de la région.
C'est une voiture
que j'ai achetée à un particulier.
Une voiture qui a été radiée
et qui n'est plus en circulation.
Je l'ai récupéré pour rien,
et après je revends les pièces.
Je me débrouille très bien.
Un travail au noir
qui lui rapporterait 800 euros par mois,
soit plus de 1000 euros
avec les allocations.
À Lezennes,
c'est le jour des encombrants.
Un jour important
pour Bobby et son ami Feunika.
Les deux hommes cherchent
tous les objets qui contiennent du métal.
Ça contient la ferraille.
Il y a de la ferraille là-dedans ?
- Oui.
Leur objectif, trouver
les objets les plus lourds possible.
Un peu plus loin,
sur ce trottoir, un bien précieux,
des câbles électriques.
Ils contiennent du cuivre,
un métal dont les coûts sont élevés.
Les deux hommes
espèrent en tirer un bon prix.
Certains habitants de Lezennes
ne voient pas toujours ça d'un bon œil.
Monsieur, vous semblez être
de mauvaise humeur.
Avec eux, oui.
J'ai été cambriolé deux fois.
Excusez-moi,
je ne peux plus les voir.
Ce sont eux forcément ?
Oui.
- Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est comme ça.
Il y en a trop en France.
Il faut être logique.
Pourquoi vous venez en France ?
C'est vice versa,
les français viennent aussi chez nous.
Si en un an
tous les Roumains, les Syriens etcetera
viennent en France, au bout d'un moment
nous deviendrons pauvre comme la Roumanie.
Malgré l'hostilité ambiante,
Bobby poursuit son travail.
Rangez ça bien avant de partir.
Retour au camp.
C'est ici qu'ils trient
la récolte du jour.
Bobby va essayer d'en tirer
le meilleur profit chez un ferrailleur.
Pour éviter la vente illégale de métaux,
la loi française oblige
les ferrailleurs à payer par chèque.
Bobby n'a pas de compte en banque
et préfère prendre du cash.
Pour ça, il lui suffit
de parcourir quelques kilomètres.
Direction la Belgique.
Ce ferrailleur est habitué
à traiter avec les Roms,
et il ne s'en plaint pas.
Ils trient bien avant.
Comme vous voyez, la ferraille d'abord.
Une fois ici,
ils distinguent chaque sorte.
Neuf kilogrammes d'inox
achetés à six euros.
Un kilogramme de laiton
pour une valeur de deux euros.
Ce qui aujourd'hui va lui rapporter
le plus sont des batteries.
Cinquante-et-un kilogrammes de batterie.
Ça, c'est combien ?
- Quinze euros trente.
C'est maintenant l'heure de la paye.
Bilan de l'opération, 61 euros.
C'est peu.
Il y a un mois que je travaille
pour récupérer cette ferraille.
Il faut aussi payer l'essence,
20 euros pour essence.
Du coup,
il ne reste pas grand-chose.
Cette fois, le ferrailleur
a pris toute la marchandise.
Ce n'est pas toujours le cas.
Des Roms lui amènent
souvent des objets probablement volés.
Ça arrive, une fois par semaine
au moins qu'on refuse.
On ne prend pas du neuf.
Du laiton, des robinets,
des tuyaux neufs, on ne prend pas.
Même si
c'est 10 kilogrammes.
En ce qui concerne les grands poids, il
faut un papier de l'usine de provenance,
qui atteste qu'on peut prendre.
On se couvre comme ça.
Si le ferrailleur est aussi exigeant
sur les métaux qu'il achète,
c'est parce qu'il peut être condamné
pour recel de marchandise volée.
Bobby a accepté de se laisser filmer
car son activité n'a rien d'illégal.
Pourtant, dans la région,
beaucoup d'habitants se plaignent.
De nombreux vols auraient été commis
depuis la multiplication
des campements autour de Lille.
Croix, une ville de 20 000 habitants,
dans la banlieue huppée de Lille.
Ici, on croise
dans les rues des voitures de luxe.
Les jolies villas sont nombreuses.
Elles se cachent
derrière de belles palissades.
À quelques encablures,
un bidonville d'une centaine de familles.
Depuis l'arrivée des Roms,
Damien Hackett est sur ses gardes.
Cet agriculteur élève des volailles.
Une nuit, il a surpris
des voleurs dans son jardin.
Ils longent puisque
le camp est là-bas derrière.
Puis, ils remontent chez nous,
et ouvrent les barrières.
Ils nous ont pris
une quarantaine de poules,
les cinq paons,
les trois oies et puis quelques pintades.
Ils se sont attaqués aussi
aux chèvres, ils en ont pris deux.
Qu'est-ce que vous avez fait
pour les faire partir ?
On a tiré en l'air une fois et de là,
ils sont partis comme des lapins.
Depuis, Damien Hackett
a tendu du fil de nylon
pour faire trébucher les voleurs.
Pour qu'ils tombent, c'est ça ?
- Oui.
Il faut leur faire
un peu des surprises.
Préjudice
pour Damien, 1 000 euros.
Aujourd'hui,
sa basse-cour est déserte.
Il ne lui reste plus
qu'une seule poule et quatre canards.
Damien Hackett
n'est pas la seule victime.
À une centaine de mètres de là,
Laurence Catry a perdu beaucoup plus.
Propriétaire de ces hangars,
elle les louait il y a quelques
mois encore à des entreprises.
Aujourd'hui,
ses locaux sont vides.
Plus personne
ne veut s'installer chez elle.
Car depuis l'arrivée des Roms,
son site n'est plus très sûr.
Dans un premier temps,
voilà, ça a été scié.
Puis ils passaient
par l'ouverture,
ils se sont introduits
au sein du groupe frigorifique,
et ils ont dérobé
les tuyaux en cuivre et les condensateurs.
Préjudice pour Laurence,
50 000 euros.
Omar qui travaille avec elle,
a surpris les voleurs en flagrant délit.
C'étaient des Roms
venus du camp voisin.
Il y en avait un qui faisait le guet ici,
trois adultes, un enfant.
Ils m'ont laissé l'enfant derrière eux,
et les trois adultes sont partis
en courant par ici.
En courant, voilà ce que j'ai trouvé.
La barrière carrément cassée.
D'ailleurs, les groupes
sont encore là, dans le fameux trou.
Dans leur fuite,
les Roms ont jeté les condensateurs.
Du coup,
ils sont cassés et inutilisables.
Ils les ont jetés devant moi.
Alors que je leur ai demandé
de ne pas jeter, quitte à les monnayer.
Je pense
qu'ils ne m'ont pas compris.
Il faut dire que les locaux de Laurence
sont situés juste à côté du camp Rom.
Quand les policiers arrivent
quelques heures plus tard,
les voleurs ont déjà pris
la poudre d'escampette.
Laurence a déposé plusieurs
plaintes pour vols et dégradations.
En voilà une, deux,
trois, quatre et cinq.
Depuis fin août.
Aucune de ces plaintes
n'a été suivie d'effets.
Ça me rend insomniaque,
parce que j'ai trop peur qu'on
trouve tout vandalisé dans le bâtiment.
On a plusieurs bâtiments dans la métropole
qui sont complètement vandalisés.
Vous imaginez le fruit du travail
qui est vandalisé comme ça ?
Ce n'est pas possible.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Les Roms ont ouvert un passage pour jeter
leurs ordures et faire leurs besoins.
En un mois, le terrain
de Laurence est devenu un dépotoir.
Imaginez le prix
de la remise en état.
Remettre les buttes
dans leur état initial.
Tout nettoyer
après leur passage,
sans être sûr que cette situation
ne se renouvelera pas encore une fois.
Ça c'est complètement démoralisant.
On ne voit pas le bout.
Il n'y a pas que les vols
qui dérangent les habitants de Croix.
Dans cette petite commune,
la mendicité
est vécue comme une agression.
Au centre-ville,
des bandes de jeunes enfants
font la manche toute la journée.
Madame, donnez
quelques centimes pour acheter à manger.
Cet homme prétend être leur père.
Il ne faut pas les filmer.
Il n'apprécie pas
la présence de notre caméra.
Les adultes ne font
pas seulement mendier des enfants.
Certains les utilisent
aussi parfois pour voler.
Paris, place de l'Opéra,
près des grands magasins.
Un quartier touristique.
Tous les jours,
les policiers traquent les voleurs
aux distributeurs automatiques de billets.
JP travaille en civil
pour se fondre dans la foule.
Il vient de repérer deux Roms rôdant
autour d'un distributeur de billets.
Ça y est,
les deux garçons !
Ces deux enfants ont attendu
le meilleur moment pour attaquer.
Les deux y vont là.
Le grand à gauche et le petit à droite !
Ça y est, il a appuyé sur le bouton.
Ils sont à proximité de la dame !
Le plus grand à gauche
a déjà appuyé sur le montant.
La carte bleue de la jeune femme ressort.
Elle pense que l'opération est annulée
alors qu'en fait,
les billets sortent du distributeur.
Les voleurs s'en emparent
quand JP intervient.
C'est la police madame.
Vous êtes touriste ?
- Oui.
Asseyez-vous !
Assis !
La femme est une touriste
espagnole de passage à Paris.
On ira au commissariat,
vous allez déposer plainte,
on va vous restituer votre argent.
Ça ira ?
Les voleurs ont dérobé
50 euros à cette touriste.
Pour y parvenir,
ils n'ont pas hésité à cracher
sur le clavier et l'écran du distributeur.
Ils crachent pour que la femme
ait du dégoût et parte vite,
et ils restent, attendent 10 secondes
à peu près pour que les billets sortent.
Quand elle récupère la carte, ils viennent
faire diversion en crachant et partent.
pour que la femme
retire rapidement sa carte et parte.
Ils restent attendre
les billets qui sortiront.
Je retirais
l'argent du distributeur,
les enfants se sont approchés
et ont fait quelque chose de curieux.
Tout s'est passé très vite. Ils sont
apparus aussi vite qu'ils ont disparu.
La police m'a dit
que je venais d'être victime d'un vol.
Ces enfants sont mineurs.
Ils seront donc bientôt
relâchés par le juge.
Pour lutter
contre cette délinquance,
les policiers
doivent confondre les têtes de réseau,
c'est-à-dire
les adultes qui les exploitent.
Des enquêtes
souvent longues et difficiles.
Cet homme, appelons-le Adrian,
45 ans, a été condamné
en septembre 2012 à cinq ans de prison
pour avoir entraîné des enfants à voler.
Ce verdict est le fruit
d'une enquête incroyable
que nous suivions depuis cinq ans.
L'affaire commence
dans les locaux de l'unité de recherche
et d'investigation.
Une équipe de policiers
s'attaque à une bande de jeunes Roms
qui opèrent sur plusieurs
arrondissements de Paris.
Leur spécialité, le vol
aux distributeurs automatiques de billets.
C'est Agathe
qui dirige cette enquête.
Ici, on voit bien
que la victime saisie son code.
Lui, il attend que le code soit tapé
pour ensuite approcher sa pétition
ou son journal
une fois que le code est tapé.
Ensuite,
il appuie sur la touche retrait.
La dame reprend sa carte.
Affolée, elle s'en va.
Ayant déjà appuyé
sur la touche retrait,
il récupère l'argent
et le met dans la bouche et s'en va.
S'il met les billets dans la bouche,
c'est pour les avaler
en cas d'interpellation.
Ça c'est une autre équipe.
Une autre équipe, plus violente.
Quand les victimes se défendent,
les voleurs peuvent même être agressifs.
Un est tombé.
Un qui le protège.
Il mange l'argent,
ils s'en vont.
Grâce à ces images
de vidéosurveillance,
les enquêteurs
identifient les jeunes voleurs.
Le plus difficile est de les localiser.
Ils habiteraient
dans des bidonvilles en Seine-Saint-Denis.
Il y a des vols
tous les jours et plusieurs par jour.
Au début, c'était un de temps en temps.
Maintenant, c'est vraiment un fléau.
Agathe s'équipe
d'une caméra cachée,
qui va lui permettre
de filmer discrètement dans le camp.
Pour entrer,
les policiers ont trouvé un prétexte.
Ils disent venir
pour faire un recensement.
Dès l'entrée,
ils sont bloqués par le Bouli Basch,
le chef du camp.
Ça ne sert à rien.
Plus personne n'entre là.
C'est fini, monsieur.
On est 670 personnes.
C'est tout.
C'est fini.
Merci Monsieur.
Bon courage !
- Bon courage !
Les policiers n'insistent pas.
Agathe a réussi à tourner quelques images.
De retour au commissariat,
avec son équipe elle va les comparer
aux fichiers des jeunes voleurs.
Ce n'est pas sûr,
mais, il y a des grandes chances
pour qu'ils soient tous dans ce camp.
Déjà on a un, deux,
trois, quatre qui sont sûrs.
C'est tout.
Sur les douze délinquants,
les policiers en ont identifié
quatre dans ce camp.
L'interpellation est prévue
pour le lendemain, à l'aube.
Il est 5 h 00 du matin.
Quatre-vingts policiers
et gendarmes sont réquisitionnés.
Le commissaire
va faire son briefing.
Il insiste sur le caractère mafieux
du réseau qu'ils veulent démanteler.
On va essayer
de démontrer que,
derrière des mineurs qui volent,
qui sont interpellés et relâchés
dans l'après-midi,
il y a toute une structure mafieuse.
Ce sont des mineurs très jeunes,
parfois ils ont jusqu'à 13 ans.
Ce sont des gens qui sont auteurs,
mais en même temps victimes
puisqu'ils sont exploités.
C'est une affaire qui a un certain
retentissement. Je compte sur vous.
Les forces de l'ordre encerclent
le camp et entrent dans le bidonville.
Un hélicoptère éclaire
les lieux avec un projecteur.
Chaque cabane,
chaque tente doit être visitée.
L'effet de surprise est total.
Les suspects n'ont pas le temps
d'être agressifs ni de prendre la fuite.
Agathe repère très vite un
des jeunes voleurs présumés.
Toi, tu es interpellé.
Demandes-lui ses parents.
Tu vas nous montrer tes parents.
Que faites-vous Agathe ?
On met les serflex
pour les reconnaître.
On les interpelle
et après on les placera en garde à vue.
Préparé à l'avance,
ces bracelets en plastique permettent
d'identifier les petits voleurs de DAB.
En fait, les policiers
découvrent non pas quatre,
mais une dizaine de mineurs
qu'ils avaient repérés sur les vidéos.
D'ailleurs, les enfants sont contents
de se reconnaître
sur les fichiers de la police.
Ils savent
qu'ils ne risquent pas grand-chose.
Montre.
- Où es tu sur la photo ?
Ce qui intéresse les policiers,
c'est d'abord le chef du camp.
Il est majeur et serait à la tête
de ce réseau de voleurs.
C'est le chef.
Bonjour.
- Bonjour.
Vous êtes le seul chef de camp ?
- Oui.
De tout le camp il n'y a que vous ?
Il est placé en garde à vue
pour traite des êtres humains.
Traite des êtres humains.
Un chef d'inculpation lourd
qui ne semble pas l'inquiéter.
Tu suis mon collègue.
L'homme est emmené jusqu'au commissariat.
Son audition va bientôt commencer.
Dans le camp,
les policiers passent à la deuxième étape,
les perquisitions.
Leur objectif est de trouver du liquide
ou des mandats envoyés en Roumanie.
Autant de documents
visant à prouver l'existence du réseau.
Sur cette femme au foulard, les policiers
trouvent 1 000 euros en liquide.
Elle prétend qu'il s'agit
de l'argent de la mendicité.
Les gens ne donnent pas
les billets aux mendiants.
Les policiers continuent leurs fouilles.
Dans le camp, personne n'est oublié.
Ni les enfants,
ni même les nourrissons.
Les parents ont tendance à cacher l'argent
dans les couches ou dans les chaussettes.
Parce qu'ils pensent
qu'on ne va pas fouiller les petits.
Ils ont tendance
à les cacher n'importe où.
Au bout
de plusieurs heures de fouille,
les policiers trouvent
un élément clé de l'affaire,
un bordereau d'envoi d'argent
à destination de la Roumanie.
C'est bon pour vous Pascal ?
- Oui.
Ça veut dire que 5 000 euros
ont été envoyés vers la Roumanie.
Cinq-mille euros
c'est une belle somme.
Elle a été envoyée par un adulte
à son frère d'après ses explications.
Fin de l'opération.
Les policiers ont trouvé
plusieurs bordereaux d'envois
à destination de la Roumanie,
pour des sommes importantes.
Plus de 10 000 euros.
Retour dans les locaux
de l'unité de recherche
et d'investigation.
Pour les policiers,
le travail n'est pas terminé.
Après avoir identifié les enfants,
ils vont tenter de leur faire avouer
qu'ils volent pour le compte d'un chef.
Est-ce qu'on leur enlève
les serflex maintenant ?
Placés en cellule,
les mineurs vont être
entendus chacun à leur tour.
Cet adolescent
est un des fils du chef de camp.
Est-ce qu'ils sont venus
de leur plein gré en France
ou ils ont été amenés
par obligation ici ?
Non, je suis venu tout seul.
Comment il fait pour gagner de l'argent ?
Est-ce qu'il en gagne ?
Je fais la manche.
Au bout d'une heure d'audition,
l'enquêteur perd patience.
Si tu me dis non à chaque fois,
personne ne m'oblige,
je ne vole pas,
je fais la manche, ce n'est pas vrai.
Je sais que ce n'est pas vrai.
On perd du temps.
Son papa envoie de l'argent en Roumanie.
On a trouvé ce matin.
D'accord ? Beaucoup d'argent.
On sait que vous volez,
vous donner et ça part.
Ce n'est pas pour acheter les vêtements.
L'association vous en offre.
Ce n'est pas acheter en magasin.
L'adolescent finit
par reconnaître qu'il vole,
mais il affirme
qu'il agit pour son propre compte.
Ses parents ne seraient
au courant de rien.
Tous les enfants
vont tenir le même discours.
Au terme de plusieurs mois d'enquête,
les policiers évaluent les sommes volées
par les enfants à plus de 100 000 euros.
Le tribunal de Paris a condamné
le chef et quatre autres adultes
à des peines
de cinq à six ans de prison.
Quant aux enfants, ils ont été placés
en centre éducatif ouvert
d'où ils sont sortis très rapidement.
À Paris, neuf affaires comme
celle-ci sont actuellement en cours.
En France, 400 camps sont installés
autour des grandes villes,
principalement en région parisienne.
Pour lutter contre leur implantation,
le gouvernement procède
à des mesures d'expulsion.
L'an dernier,
165 camps ont été évacués.
C'est deux fois
plus qu'en 2012.
Retour à Croix,
dans le Nord.
Le camp
que nous avions filmé
quelques semaines plus tôt
est encerclé par la police.
Les journalistes
sont tenus à distance.
C'est interdit.
Pour l'instant,
tous les journalistes sont là-bas.
D'accord.
Les Roms ont quelques
minutes pour faire leurs affaires.
Vous allez où ?
- Je ne sais pas.
Les caravanes qui ne peuvent
pas être tractées par leurs propriétaires,
sont emmenées à la fourrière.
Quant aux cabanes, elles sont détruites
à grands coups de bulldozer.
Un homme vient à notre rencontre.
Florine, le mécanicien qui prétendait
gagner 800 euros par mois
en revendant des pièces
détachées au garagiste.
Ils ont cassé toutes les caravanes.
Les forces de l'ordre
ont quitté le secteur,
mais tout n'est
pas encore démoli.
La fin de l'expulsion
est prévue pour le lendemain.
Nous en profitons
pour entrer dans le camp.
Ma caravane était là-bas,
derrière les barrières.
Qu'est-ce que je fais
avec mes bébés ? Je les donne ?
Qu'est-ce que vous allez faire ?
Vous allez dormir où ce soir ?
Sous les étoiles.
Ces caravanes
n'ont pas encore été évacuées.
Un court sursis.
Maria et sa famille s'attendent
à devoir quitter les lieux
dès le lendemain matin.
Ça y est, c'est l'heure du départ ?
Maria affirme n'avoir
aucune solution de repli,
aucun logement en Roumanie.
D'après la loi,
ces familles privées de caravanes auraient
dû être relogées par la préfecture,
mais aucune solution
d'hébergement ne leur a été proposée.
C'est donc dehors
qu'elles passeront la nuit.
Pour se protéger du froid,
des feux ont été allumés
et des abris de fortune
construits à la va-vite avec une bâche
et quelques planches.
Je suis désolée pour ce qui se passe ici.
Maintenant, quand je dors la nuit,
je suis comme un oiseau perdu.
Ce n'est pas une vie pour les enfants.
Ces expulsions ne les
découragent pas pour autant.
Quelques jours plus tard,
nous retrouvons Maria et Florine.
Ils viennent de s'installer à Lesquin,
à 10 kilomètres de leur ancien camp.
Cette fois-ci, la police tente
de les déloger dès leur arrivée.
Florine, bien décidé à ne pas
se laisser faire, tient tête.
Les policiers quittent le terrain.
Tu penses rester
longtemps ici dans ce camp ?
Oui, je resterai
jusqu'à la décision du tribunal.
En réalité, la police
peut évacuer un terrain
sans décision du tribunal,
à condition que le propriétaire
en fasse la demande dans les 48 heures.
Dans ce cas présent,
le propriétaire ne s'est jamais manifesté.
Le délai des 48 heures est écoulé,
un nouveau camp de Roms est né.
Certains des Roms
expulsés décident de repartir
quelques semaines en Roumanie.
Depuis l'entrée de ce pays
dans l'Union européenne,
les Roms ont le droit
de circuler librement dans toute l'Europe.
Vous allez voir que les allers-retours
sont soigneusement organisés.
Chauffeurs, voitures,
tarifs, tout est prévu,
et le système
fonctionne parfaitement bien.
Nous avons réussi
à identifier un de ces réseaux.
Nous sommes dans la banlieue parisienne.
Cet homme a accepté
de nous emmener jusqu'en Roumanie.
Tarzan est chauffeur.
Il se prépare pour un long voyage.
Il possède deux camionnettes, une jaune,
et une blanche conduite par un employé.
Tarzan soigne le service.
Il va chercher
ses clients à domicile, dans les camps.
Les passagers emmènent en Roumanie
tout ce qu'ils ont récupéré en France,
pendant des mois,
voire des années.
Il est 17 h 00, Tarzan
emmène quatre familles.
Douze personnes au total
pour un périple de 2000 kilomètres.
Deux fois par semaine,
Tarzan traverse quatre pays,
France, Allemagne, Autriche,
Hongrie avant d'arriver en Roumanie.
Combien de temps on va mettre ?
On va rouler pendant 22 heures.
Vingt-deux heures, quasiment sans arrêt.
Dans son minibus, Damian,
sa femme et leurs deux enfants.
En France,
ils vivent de la mendicité.
Depuis deux ans,
ils ne sont pas rentrés chez eux.
Je dois rentrer aujourd'hui
car ma maison s'est écroulée.
Je dois la réparer pour avoir un endroit
où habiter quand je déciderai de rentrer.
Damian va retrouver là-bas
ses quatre autres enfants.
Ils ont trouvé refuge dans la famille.
Tu es content
de rentrer en Roumanie ?
Non,
mais je suis obligé de rentrer.
En Roumanie, je n'ai pas la possibilité
de donner à manger à ma famille.
Je ne peux pas les habiller.
Je préfère rester en France
pour essayer de m'en sortir.
Pour Damian, un voyage comme
celui-ci représente une petite fortune,
100 euros par adulte,
50 euros par enfant, 300 euros au total.
Pour éviter les péages,
Tarzan prend la nationale.
Pour passer le temps,
les voyageurs regardent des DVD,
des clips de musique tzigane.
Après une nuit de trajet,
nous arrivons en Autriche.
Cela fait 15 heures
que nous roulons. C'est la première étape.
Tout le monde s'arrête ici,
les roumains, les bulgares.
Cette aire de repos
est connue de toute la communauté.
Pour les passagers, c'est l'occasion
de se dégourdir les jambes
et de rencontrer
d'autres Roms qui vivent en France.
Ça va monsieur ?
Pour reprendre des forces, les voyageurs
font une halte à la cafétéria.
Des trajets comme celui-ci,
Floriane, Simone et leur fils
en font deux par an.
Cela fait cinq ans
qu'ils vivent en France.
Une demi-heure plus tard,
il faut déjà repartir.
Jusqu'à maintenant,
ça va, c'est bien.
Vous avez dormi ?
Il n'a pas bien dormi,
Il avait froid.
Floriane et sa famille
ont payé 250 euros pour le voyage.
S'ils rentrent en Roumanie,
c'est pour voir leurs quatre filles
et aussi
pour ramener de l'argent au pays.
Encore quelques kilomètres
et le convoi arrive en Hongrie.
Dans ce pays, Tarzan
conduit plus lentement
pour ne pas attirer
l'attention des policiers.
Même s'il n'y a pas de problème,
ils peuvent toujours en créer.
Tarzan sait de quoi il parle.
Lors de son dernier voyage,
il affirme qu'il a dû donner
450 euros aux policiers hongrois.
Le genre d'imprévu
qui réduit considérablement ses bénéfices.
On est en Hongrie.
Pour le moment,
ils passent la frontière sans problème.
Une centaine de kilomètres plus loin,
une voiture de police nous arrête.
Ils ne nous ont pas manqués.
Ils attendent des clients.
Tarzan descend, nous l'accompagnons,
mais le policier nous demande
de remonter dans la camionnette.
Vous, restez là-bas.
Je n'ai pas le droit d'y aller ?
Tu as entendu ?
- Non, mais ça se comprend.
Tu ne peux pas y aller ?
- Non, tu as bien vu, il m'a chassé.
Pas de témoin. Tarzan se retrouve
seul avec les policiers.
Nous filmons de loin
avec une caméra cachée.
Quelques minutes plus tard,
Tarzan reprend le volant.
Que s'est-il passé ?
Il voulait que je paye 100 euros
pour défaut de siège enfant.
Tu as payé ?
- Je lui ai donné 40 euros dans la main.
Quarante euros ?
- Oui.
Je préfère donner 40 euros à un policier
plutôt que de payer 100 euros d'amende.
Tu vois finalement
que la corruption arrange tout le monde.
Après 30 heures de voyage,
soit huit de plus que prévu,
nous passons la frontière roumaine.
On arrive en Roumanie.
C'est à Tinca à l'ouest du pays,
que Tarzan dépose sa première passagère.
Il s'arrête juste devant chez elle.
Pour le chauffeur,
c'est l'heure de se faire payer.
C'est 100 euros pour la dame.
Il est minuit, Tarzan repart
pour déposer les autres passagers.
Combien tu gagnes pour huit personnes ?
Je gagne entre 400 et 500 euros.
À raison de deux voyages
par semaine,
Tarzan gagnerait donc plus
de 3 000 euros par mois nets d'impôts.
C'est maintenant au tour de Florian
et Simone d'arriver à la maison.
À notre grande surprise,
ici, ils ne vivent pas
dans une baraque en planches,
mais dans une vraie maison en brique,
avec l'électricité et tout le confort.
Après quatre mois d'absence,
ils retrouvent leurs quatre
filles laissées sur place.
Tu es contente ?
Pour le moment,
Simone a du travail.
Elle doit ranger
tout ce qu'ils ont ramené de France.
Ici, c'est pour le bébé,
ici c'est la vaisselle.
Là ce sont mes chaussures,
et celles du bébé.
Ici ce sont des ustensiles de cuisine
- Des couvertures, des draps.
Il n'y a pas de couvertures
Tu as trouvé ça
dans les poubelles en France ?
Oui.
Tu ne les as pas acheté ?
- Non ?
Trop cher ?
- On a récupéré dans les poubelles.
Tu peux juste ouvrir
le dessus, pour me montrer ?
Demain tu pourras filmer.
- C'est compliqué.
D'accord. On viendra demain après-midi.
- D'accord.
Le lendemain,
nous retournons voir Simone et Florian.
Ils vivent à l'entrée du quartier Rom.
Nous remarquons de belles villas,
aussi plusieurs maisons en construction,
dont celle de Simone et Florian.
C'est grâce à l'argent gagné en France
que les Roms financent leurs travaux.
Nous découvrirons
qu'ils n'ont pas envie d'en parler.
Tu es sûr que Florian n'est
pas là pour que je lui parle ?
Il ne veut pas me parler.
Tu ne peux pas me donner
une raison ou me dire juste pourquoi ?
Non.
- Au moins pour que je comprenne.
Désolée.
- Merci.
Au revoir.
- Au revoir.
Il ne faut filmer pas ici.
- J'ai compris.
Ce que Simone ne veut pas nous montrer,
c'est sa grande maison en construction.
Une villa qui n'a rien à voir avec la vie
de mendiante qu'elle mène en France.
Tous les Roms n'habitent pas
dans de belles maisons.
En Roumanie, la plupart d'entre eux vivent
dans des ghettos à la lisière des villes.
Tinca est une bourgade rurale
de 20 000 habitants.
Ici comme partout, les Roms
sont regroupés dans le même quartier.
Un quartier abandonné où les ruelles
ne sont même pas goudronnées.
Les maisons sont vétustes,
la pauvreté est partout.
C'est ici que vit Damian,
un des Roms avec lequel nous avons voyagé.
Cette maison en torchis,
c'est tout ce qu'il possède.
Il est revenu en Roumanie pour la réparer.
Avec de l'eau et de la terre,
il colmate les brèches.
La pluie a creusé
et ça a fait rentrer l'eau à l'intérieur.
Ce n'est pas tout.
Les planches de la toiture
ont été enlevées.
Des voleurs ont profité de son absence
pour s'introduire dans la maison.
Tout ce qu'il y avait dans l'armoire,
les couvertures, les oreillers,
les vêtements, ils ont tout pris.
En attendant de remettre
sa maison en état,
Damian et sa famille
vivent chez sa cousine.
Une mère de cinq enfants.
Une seule pièce à vivre
pour onze personnes,
l'espace est restreint.
À peine arrivé dans son village,
Damian regrette déjà la France.
La vie est meilleure là-bas,
on arrive à se débrouiller pour manger.
Alors qu'ici on n'y arrive pas.
En France, je faisais la manche,
je récupérais à manger dans des marchés.
Damian, comment fais-tu ici
pour manger avec tes enfants ?
Je ne sais pas
comment je vais faire.
Le problème c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'argent pour acheter du pain.
Comme il n'y a pas de travail,
il n'y a pas d'argent.
On n'a rien mangé aujourd'hui.
Damian n'a qu'une obsession,
faire bouillir la marmite.
À cette saison,
la seule façon de gagner de l'argent,
c'est la cueillette des champignons.
Alors, au petit matin, Damian,
sa fille et sa nièce quittent le village.
C'est en charrette qu'ils partent pour
la forêt, située à deux kilomètres de là.
C'est ici que tous les Roms de Tinca
viennent cueillir leurs champignons.
Regarde ici !
Celui-là est bon à manger. Tu vois ?
Celui-là n'est pas bon.
Si tu le manges, il te rend fou.
Damian connaît bien les champignons.
Petit, il a passé plus de temps dans
la forêt que sur les bancs de l'école.
C'est encore le lot
des enfants roms à Tinca.
Car gagner un peu d'argent
compte plus qu'apprendre à écrire.
Tu ne vas pas à l'école ?
Pas ce matin,
car il faut aider aux champignons.
Damian prend le chemin du retour.
Ce matin, la cueillette
n'est pas fructueuse.
Retour au village.
À l'entrée du quartier, chaque jour,
des Roms vendent leurs champignons.
Voici les acheteurs.
Ils ne sont pas très généreux.
Ils donnent deux euros
pour un kilogramme de champignons.
Pour Damian,
l'affaire n'est pas très rentable.
Combien tu gagnes ?
Quatre lei ?
Oui, on va acheter à manger avec ça.
Quatre lei, soit un euro.
Voilà ce que Damien a gagné
en une matinée de travail.
De retour à la maison,
le déjeuner est léger.
À Tinca, les Roms
ont peu d'opportunités de travail.
Pourtant, à une autre époque,
tous les Roms avaient un emploi.
C'était sous la dictature de Ceausescu.
Une époque que Damian
regrette même aujourd'hui.
Il y avait les fermes coopératives.
On était tous engagés
sur les chantiers, dans les fermes.
il y avait du travail partout.
Tu as connu ce temps-là ?
Oui, j'étais embauché à l'époque.
Pendant six ans, Damien
a touché un salaire de 400 euros par mois.
À la fin de la dictature,
les coopératives ont fermé,
laissant sur le carreau
des milliers de familles Roms.
Aujourd'hui, le marché de l'emploi
est réservé en priorité aux roumains.
Partout en Roumanie,
les Roms sont des parias,
victimes d'un racisme ouvertement affiché.
À Baia Mare, une ville industrielle
à 200 kilomètres au nord de Tinca,
le maire a même construit un mur
pour séparer
le quartier Rom du reste de la ville.
Derrière ce mur, un ensemble
de barres d'immeubles vétustes.
À l'entrée, un jeune toxicomane
sniffant du solvant industriel.
Pour en savoir plus
sur cette discrimination,
nous interrogeons
les habitants du quartier.
Personne n'accepte
d'en parler ouvertement.
Nous utilisons
donc une caméra cachée.
Cet homme est roumain,
et il nous dit à quel point il est content
que ce mur ait été construit.
Ici, tu vois, avant qu'il y ait le mur,
ils jetaient leurs déchets partout.
Même sur la route.
Il est très bien ce mur.
Avant, j'avais peur
de passer ici, même en voiture.
Parce qu'on se faisait caillasser.
Je vais vous montrer
dans quelle saleté ils vivent.
Entre les immeubles,
des tas d'immondices.
Les camions poubelles
passaient ici avant.
Une semaine après,
c'était à nouveau comme ça.
Après, ils disent que la mairie
ne fait rien pour eux.
Tout à coup,
une voix d'enfant nous interpelle.
Incroyable !
À la fenêtre, Florina,
l'une des filles de Maria et Florine,
la famille que nous avions
rencontrée à Croix.
Souvenez-vous, nous les avions filmés
au moment de l'évacuation du camp.
La petite nous invite
à visiter l'appartement
qu'elle dit occuper avec sa famille.
Nous traversons
des couloirs crasseux et sombres.
C'est ici chez toi ?
- Oui.
Les parents
de Florina ne sont pas là.
Nous décidons
de revenir plus tard.
Dans les couloirs,
un homme nous interpelle.
Il dit être le Bouli Basch,
autrement dit le chef
des Roms de ce quartier.
Pour lui, ce mur est une preuve
de la discrimination
dont les Roms sont victimes.
Nous considérons que c'est notre liberté
de mouvement qui est entravée.
Il n'y a aucun endroit où on sépare
les gens en fonction de leur ethnie.
Franchement, est-ce que
vous connaissez en Europe
un endroit où les gens sont entourés
d'un mur à cause de leur nationalité
ou de leur ethnie ?
Quelques minutes plus tard,
nous retrouvons Maria
au milieu
de cette décharge à ciel ouvert.
Le seul point d'eau du ghetto.
Maria a quitté
le quartier il y a deux ans.
Elle le retrouve
dans le même état d'insalubrité.
Il y a beaucoup
de microbes, c'est sale.
Je suis malade,
j'ai de l'asthme.
L'odeur me gêne.
On vit dans des conditions
pires que les animaux.
Même les animaux
y sont mieux traités.
Pourquoi Maria est-elle
rentrée en Roumanie ?
Nous la suivons
jusqu'à son appartement.
Elle nous raconte alors
une histoire invérifiable.
Elle aurait quitté la France
parce qu'elle aurait été agressée et volée
par un autre Rom
de son campement.
Il est entré un soir dans ma caravane
et il m'a pris de l'argent.
Il m'a pris 10 000 euros.
Tout l'argent qu'on avait économisé
pendant deux ans en France.
Maria en profite
pour nous demander 500 euros
afin de meubler son appartement.
Tu peux nous aider
pour qu'on achète un lit ?
Donne-nous de l'argent
pour les enfants qui n'ont pas mangé.
Maria se met même à pleurer
en nous racontant une nouvelle fois
l'histoire de son agression.
Cette fois-ci,
les enfants sourient.
Quelques minutes plus tard,
Florine arrive.
Lui aussi sort le grand jeu.
Je suis très émue que tu sois là.
J'ai cru ne jamais te revoir.
Florine confirme
la version de sa femme.
Dix mille euros volés.
Leur séjour
en France s'est mal terminé.
Florine et sa famille
s'apprêtent à passer l'hiver à Baia Mare.
Pour inciter les Roms
à rester en Roumanie,
certaines villes de France
ont lancé une opération originale.
Par exemple, la ville de Lyon,
qui compte une forte communauté Rom,
investit beaucoup d'argent à Tinca
pour améliorer
la vie quotidienne des habitants.
C'est Marinel, une figure du ghetto Rom,
qui est chargé d'exécuter le projet.
On a installé
le courant avec les français.
Il y a un an encore,
ce quartier était plongé
dans l'obscurité dès la nuit tombée.
Aujourd'hui,
les rues principales
et une cinquantaine
de maisons bénéficient de l'électricité.
C'est bien,
ça change tout ?
Le courant, c'est la joie.
Combien ça coûte par mois ?
Dix à 20 euros par mois.
S'il n'y a pas d'argent,
il n'y a pas de courant.
Vingt euros, une somme importante
pour ces familles très pauvres,
qui n'ont pas toujours
les moyens de payer leurs factures.
Autre amélioration apportée
par la ville de Lyon, le tout à l'égout.
Ce dont Marinel est le plus fier,
c'est cette grande maison,
un centre flambant neuf
avec machines à laver, douches, toilettes.
Au total, la ville de Lyon a versé plus de
300 000 euros pour ces installations.
Ce programme est basé sur l'hygiène.
Parce que c'est un aspect
très important de l'éducation.
Nous avons remarqué qu'il y a
une grande discrimination des Roms
vis-à-vis de leur aspect
vestimentaire et de leur hygiène.
C'est pour cela que nous avons commencé
le programme de cette façon-là.
Les investissements français
inciteront ils les Roms à rester au pays ?
Pas si sûr.
De nouveaux convois
repartent tous les jours vers la France.
Dans ce jardin public, un groupe de Roms
attend le minibus de Tarzan.
Parmi eux, Dana, 15 ans.
Après un mois passé en Roumanie,
elle repart déjà en région parisienne.
Mon sac, c'est ça.
Un petit sac de voyage car l'essentiel
de ses affaires est resté en France.
Ça fait longtemps
que tu vis en France.
Ça fait comme ça.
Huit ans ?
- Oui.
Huit ans qu'elle mendie
en France dans les rues de Paris.
Dana repart
toujours avec le sourire.
Ce n'est pas drôle de faire la manche.
N'est-ce pas ?
S'ils donnent, tant mieux.
Sinon c'est toujours mieux qu'ici.
Quelques minutes plus tard,
les camionnettes de Tarzan arrivent.
Tout le monde embarque.
Dans une vingtaine d'heures,
ils seront de retour
dans les rues de Paris.